mais que fait l'ogre texte de joëlle
ecormier illustrations de michel boucher
édition océan jeunesse il adore les
petits enfants surtout à la sauce
moutarde
il rote rohff et grogne sans vergogne
c'est un ogre parfait il mitonne un osso
buco dans son château à défaut de
marmots
il dédicace son livre de cuisine
qu'il fasse une petite annonce
joue de la harpe d'or dans un groupe de
rock
ils mangent les miettes de pain du petit
poucet et non ce n'était pas les oiseaux
il a un rendez vous amoureux
il remporte la course dames
il promet à son dentiste qu'il ne fera
plus dans une eau sucre d'orge ils se
marient ils voyagent pour ses affaires
c'est un disney soldes c'est rose
hill chipote pour manger des sushis il
préfère les enfants cuit
il peint son acteur préféré
il est papa
il surveille de très près les
plantations de jack il a peur de son
ombre
il met ses filles au lit par ordre
alphabétique
il fait une crise d'allergie au chat
botté
il craque pour un croc en bouche et des
croquignol croustillantes
il va chercher ses enfants à l'école
il sent la chair fraîche
fuyait